ariana grande will be joining the voice
next season
as a coach and the rumors are that she's
getting paid between 20
and 25 million dollars for the gig
yesterday to virtual press conference
about the current season john legend
blake shelton weighed in on ariana
joining the panel on the next go around
ariana is one of the most gifted artists
uh in our business today
she is a a huge chopping artist
with amazing vocal skills and
and i think so many of our fans out
there
truly love her and i think she's going
to bring
additional fans to the show um you know
a a different audience to the show and i
think it's going to be great
for all of us and what we what we've
learned
i think is that our audience like some
stability
with coaches but i think it also likes
for us to introduce some new flavors to
the mix every once in a while i think
ariana is going to be
a great addition to the show i'm excited
about ariana joining the
uh the show because it's somebody new
for me to beat
i mean i'm tired of beating john every
season
i mean nick was nick's literally once
he's beating me
once nick is the easiest coach i ever
beat
in 20 seasons of doing this show the
easiest
defeat of my career was nick jonas
so i i'm looking for a challenge i think
ariana's she could be a challenge
i'm looking forward to beating her
though
okay now ariana did tweet about the news
when it was first announced
but in a new statement she says i'm so
honored and excited to join the voice
family i've been a huge fan of the show
for such a long time
i can't wait to go head-to-head with the
incredible coaches get to know these new
artists and help
to take their craft to the next level uh
francis is wondering how much does blake
get paid for the show per season
um ally was saying i'm surprised
she's doing the show she's one of the
biggest stars around
yeah what do you think keisha because
that was like katy perry numbers right
for
the first season that she joined idol
was like 25 million dollars do you think
this
makes sense to pay ariana that much
absolutely because ariana grande
taking time from her life you're really
paying for each day that you have her
film the show
each day that she's needed to promote it
she could be going on tour
doing whatever the heck else she's doing
um but this is a great
opportunity for both of them at the end
of the day ariana grande has an
incredible voice her range
her impressions are just
her style her personality she's gonna be
a perfect addition i'm gonna wanna watch
um but i think that she's gonna she's
gonna really she's got amazing
management
um in terms of catapulting her talents
and her skills and i think that
this is going to be something where
we're going to see her on the voice and
then she's going to put out an
album and a project at the same damn
time
okay i am here for this i don't even
really like to watch the voice i find
like
it makes me cry i get it comfortable
it's whatever ariana grande first of all
that pony honey
when the chair the chair her first chair
turned
if that pony doesn't hit people on the
way around
i swear i swear to god i expect a oh
it's going to be iconic
yeah this this was a this was a
brilliant move and the producers
realized
you know hey listen nobody can tour
right now it's covered you can't book a
world tour you can barely book an
american tour
these artists aren't touring so who's
the biggest name in the world we can get
i don't think beyonce is going to do the
voice
lady gaga as movie commitments ariana
grande
ariana grande is like top three biggest
star's biggest voices in the in the
world arguably
and this is a brilliant move and you pay
her
whatever it takes to get that ass and
ponytail in that red chair because you
will make it back
and that's just that's just that you
don't say no you give her everything
this will never happen again once cope
is over the world opens up
this will never happen again right right
theresa says ariana is a great bonus to
the show she isn't touring right now so
why not do the show
all the performers are amazing milo says
ariana might be famous and popular but
she'll never be on the same level as
john legend
come on uh joyce she didn't make
millions on nickelodeon
why is she suddenly worth paying 20
million dollars i would be
wait let me okay don't say your thing
respond to that keisha i have something
i'll say but respond to that
okay whoa um there's milo that's so good
if we weren't in 2021 if we were in
mariah carey era
right and ariana grande wasn't singing
songs that were pop and trendy and young
and whatever and she was singing more
adult contemporary music the way mariah
did
she would be considered as iconic as
mariah carey
she's she to me is pretty much next to
mariah and i know that people get very
upset when you say that
but that's just because she's at the
beginning of her career she's in the
cool trendy girl stage
but we're gonna watch give give ariana
10 more years of
hits give her the big iconic ballads let
her get in that bag she hasn't really
gotten in that bag yet she's still the
cool pop chick that's making these
records
her voice is immaculate guys and i know
that we
right now we're looking at the ponytail
and the personality and all that type of
sauce that she's got
but you can never take away her voice
her voice is ridiculous one of the best
voices of right now you can't take that
away from her
and let her age and like she's so
incredible why wouldn't you want her as
a mentor and she's young
okay wait a second i'm getting upset am
i part of the ariana grande fan club
yes do i send you a membership
okay i will say follow her on instagram
immediately
i will say like i'd be curious to ask
american idol if they thought
the 25 million dollars for katy perry
who are assuming she's not getting that
same money now they're in
their four seasons i think i would
curiously know do they think that paid
off do you think that 25 million dollars
for the first thing the idle paid off
because i know that first season of idol
pretty much got the same ratings as the
voice it kind of challenged the voice a
little bit
now i'm pretty sure the idol has slipped
that it's below the voice i wonder do
they think that really paid
off like the only thing i could see
people saying is that
we don't know if arya is going to draw
eyeballs to that tv show at eight
o'clock on monday night like ariana's
huge social media following
very different thing to get eyeballs
like on a show so i could see why people
think does ariana have the power in that
venue i know she's gonna have a huge
social media poll like if she does
tweets and instagram posts about this
show and like
certain contestants it's gonna be huge
but i'm not sure how many eyeballs
we saw with katy perry it didn't cost 20
million people to watch american idol it
got about the same rating as the voice
did
that first season so that's the only
thing i could see is arianna could be
worth that 25 million dollars
that's the only thing i would say if if
if you just skip around and read a lot
of what is written about american idol
when you do see stories whether it's the
morning after or leading up to episodes
ninety percent of the things written
about american idol are centered around
katy perry
90 it is always a katy perry headline
very little about the other two judges
and even less about the contestants
it's katy perry's show and they needed
someone to come in and sort of take over
and if it turns into the katy perry show
i think they're okay because the
alternative to that
is having nobody mention the show which
is where they were added
true also they're guaranteed blake
shelton and john legend are making like
30 30 finances like they're they're
bringing in the bucks so
if the men are making in that number
range i expect
any woman to come on the show to get
even if you're feeling like oh she
doesn't
deserve it blah blah blah whatever
people want to say at the end of the day
it should be pretty equal
you know male and woman i would assume
and there's no way blake or john are
doing that show for less than 20 25 you
think
ariana and katie are gonna get all this
money and they're just gonna be sitting
there as the resident
judges and they've been getting less
this whole time hell
no okay they are getting paid
someone commented who knows that this is
true but biebing commented saying blake
gets 13 million
a season which yeah i wouldn't think i
don't think they're getting 20 million i
think our enemies that makes sense to me
yeah like 100 100 right our ariana
grande will be the highest paid judge on
that show
without question yeah would you really
think that yeah
it could become an interesting thing
with kelly clarkson because now kelly
clarkson
is a proven thing to draw eyes on tv she
now has a talk show that's called the
kelly clarkson show that is now a huge
success
so now she's a proven thing that i drive
draw eyes
to televisions so i think that's so
could be an interesting thing down the
line